[Music]
i'm a fourth generation farmer here uh
we've we've uh
in 2012 was really bad i'm seeing 2012
maybe even just a little worse in 2012
right now
already feeding hay if you have to
purchase hay which we're going to
purchase probably 600 bail this year uh
you're already seeing a 65 to 85 dollar
hay
and you know it's some of that hate it
was built in the media that's what
scares me the quality of the hay that
we're gonna have to purchase because
there's nothing else growing you look
here and it's just burn up everywhere
but what i what i hope in the the
positive in the future will be
i hope we see like we did in 13 some
higher priced cattle if if we can stay
hooked and get by this drought
um i think i hope we see some hard
cattle i don't think we'll see them as
high as we did in 13 but if if we can
get higher than where we was and for
sure where we're at now i think it's a
positive
uh you know and in the future if we knew
that we was going to get rain we would
know that we how much was going to have
to buy but it's just hard to tell if
we're going to get it when we're going
to get it it's been in the future we
don't get it
we had rain here since i think june 8th
we finally got two tenths of rain about
five days ago
it was gone in 30 minutes you know so
hopefully it will get better but that's
kind of my positive is i hope the cattle
market
if we can make it
and don't have to sell out
i think the cattle market should be a
little better
being a rep for the sale barn there i
see a lot of people you know uh they
call me a lot ask what what i should do
what what should they do you know want
to know a lot of perspective about
what's going on but uh say four weeks
ago we had
80 head of cows
next week we had 180 something ahead the
next week we had 590 something ahead of
cows not just calves but cows when you
see that many cows coming to the sale
barnes problems and there's a lot of
people selling out right now which when
you demand that the man comes in of that
very that many cattle it is going to dry
the market down uh we're seeing a drop
of ten dollars a k uh you know 100 on
cows right now from from 80s in the low
six low 70s and upper 60s
and we did have a special wing sale this
last week is one reason you've seen a
lot of the big calves
big groups but the reason is also is
they're not going to hold until fall
like me i wean in the spring i sell them
in the fall i i back around my own
cattle
and with that
people's not keeping cows and calves are
keeping their calves and wind calves as
long because the the commodity prices
are high right now grains high you know
corn i seen took a little bit of a drop
that might help a little bit
but people just can't afford to feed
their cattle because they know that
there's not going to be enough hay to
feed what they don't have to keep we're
supplementing a lot right now i mean i'm
not a salesman for any feed company or
anything but we're using liquid feed
we're using salt mix to you know that
salt mix and let it meet some of the
dryer but motor grass or dryer hay get
something out of it stretch what you got
don't sell out unless you just have to
uh but use some supplements you know and
and the best thing to do is if you do
have to buy hey get it tested
if your quality of hay is good you don't
have to supplement but this year i'm
afraid we're going to get a lot of hay
that is just either too dry when it's
bailed so uh it's not going to have the
quality
go to your county extension agent get it
get it tested they can tell you if you
need to put anything if you need a
better
supplement or liquid feed or something
to get them by and just to stay in there
hey
i've i went through 12 we had another
small
winter deal you know where we fed a lot
of hay i mean i've been through some
droughts not like a lot of the old
timers
but if we can make it through i feel
like the cattle market's going to get
better after this i mean
this is something that happens every 10
or 12 to 14 years you know so just stay
in and and supplement where you need to
just don't get a lot of overcost in it
[Music]
you